نعم ،
لقد فعلنا منذ أسبوع واحد
التحليل المؤقت والتحليل الداخلي
أخبرنا بالفعل أن
لقاحنا له فعالية غير عادية لقد
أبلغنا أكثر من
90 بالمائة وهذا أكثر من 90 بالمائة
يمكن بالطبع أن يكون 95 أيضًا ولكن  الآن
أه اليوم أعلنا عن
نتائج الفعالية النهائية التي هي
النقطة النهائية الأساسية
للتجربة السريرية وقد رأينا أه لقد رأينا
170 حالة من 19 حالة من covet 19
في جميع السكان
وثمانية منهم فقط كانت في مجموعة اللقاحات
لذا  هذا يعني أن هذا يترجم
إلى فعالية 95
أو إذا كنت تريد استخدام هذا في
كل هذه الكوب التي وصفت ذلك
بعبارة أخرى ،
فإن خطر الإصابة بـ covet 19 إذا
تم
تطعيمك هو 24
أقل مقارنة بعدم وجود لقاح
وهذه بالطبع رغبة واعدة ومشجعة للغاية
وبالطبع فإن السؤال الكبير الذي يطرحه الكثير من
الناس خصوصًا في أمريكا هو
متى ستقدم طلبًا للحصول على
إذن الاستخدام في حالات الطوارئ يوم الجمعة
يوم الجمعة ، ستقدم طلبًا للحصول عليه ،
لذا بحلول نهاية هذا الأسبوع ، ستقدم
طلبًا للحصول على إذن استخدام طارئ
بناءً على هذا بناءً على
هذه
النتائج الإيجابية بالطبع fba بالإضافة
إلى ema
وغيرها  السلطات
متحمسة جدًا للقيام بذلك لإجراء هذه
المراجعة
في أسرع وقت ممكن ، واعتمادًا على مدى
سرعة
تحقيق ذلك حقًا ، قد نحصل على
تفويض
أو موافقة مشروطة بالفعل في عام 2020
مما قد يساعدنا على
بدء الحل الأول
دفعات اللقاحات بالفعل في عام 2020.
هدفنا هو توفير عدة مئات
الملايين من الجرعات
في أول أربعة إلى خمسة أشهر في عام 2021
وقد يكون لهذا تأثير بالفعل ،
نعم ، بداية التأثير
على السيطرة على
الطمع 90.  واثق من أنه إذا
سارت الأمور على ما
يرام وإذا كان لدينا إمدادات لقاح منظمة جيدًا
وأنه يمكننا الحصول على شتاء عادي
2021 ،
نعم صيف وشتاء 2021.
شركة الأدوية العملاقة pfizer ju
أصدرت st تفاصيل جديدة تمامًا حول
سلامة لقاح الفيروس التاجي الخاص بها ،
وينضم
إلينا كبير المراسلين الطبيين في CNN ، الدكتور سانجي
جوبتا ، بهذه المعلومات ، وهي
أشياء مثيرة للاهتمام حقًا هنا
سانجاي نعم ، وهذا هو نوع
المعلومات التي كنا ننتظرها
من الواضح لبعض الوقت أنه تم الإبلاغ
عن
تطوير اللقاح الذي تعرفه لعدة
أشهر الآن ، لذا
فهذه بيانات مهمة
وأريد فقط أن أشارك معك
ما تظهره البيانات ولكن أيضًا كيف قاموا
بجمعها كما تتذكر
عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص الذين تلقوا
تلقى عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص
لقاحًا وهميًا
خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية في هذه
التجربة السريرية
لشركة فايزر ، ما أرادوا رؤيته هو عدد
الأشخاص الذين ظهرت عليهم الأعراض في أي
من ذراعي التجربة
وكانوا يتطلعون إلى رؤية
ما لا يقل عن 162 شخصًا في نهاية المطاف
أصبحت أعراضًا ويمكنني شرح
الرياضيات وراء ذلك ولكن
ما يقولونه الآن بشكل أساسي أنه يمكننا إظهار
الأرقام هنا هو أنهم ضربوا  كانت
معاييرهم الخاصة بهم بطريقتين:
عندما رأوا عدد الأشخاص الذين
ظهرت عليهم الأعراض ، كانت الغالبية العظمى منهم في مجموعة الدواء الوهمي و 162
كانوا في مجموعة الدواء الوهمي ،
وكان ثمانية منهم في المجموعة التي تم تلقيحها ، حسنًا ، لذا
من الواضح جدًا استنادًا إلى  هذه
البيانات على الأقل التي تمت مشاركتها
معنا من قبل الشركة
والتي تشير إلى أن اللقاحات لها
تأثير كبير
على مرض كوفيد 19 على وجه التحديد
وأيضًا على المرض الشديد ، لذا فإن الغالبية
العظمى من الأشخاص الذين أصيبوا
بمرض حاد في إطار هذه التجارب
كانوا أيضًا في العلاج الوهمي  المجموعة مقابل المجموعة التي
تم تلقيحها ،
لذا فإن هذا حقًا هو نوع ما
نسميه بيانات الفعالية أو الفعالية
التي ستنظر فيها إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
ومرة أخرى إذا كانت هذه البيانات صحيحة ول
س لدينا سبب للشك في ذل
ولكنها تأتي فقط من الشركة لذ
ك  حتى الآن ، ولكن إذا كان هذا صحيحًا ،
فإن إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير تنظر إلى هذه البيانات ، فإنها
تقدم حجة قوية مفادها أن هذا
لقاح فعال
هو الشيء الثاني الذي تتمتع به بالسلامة ومن
ثم تصبح فعالاً  veness ، عليك أيضًا
أن تنظر إلى الأمان ، ما قالته شركة
Pfizer الآن هو أنهم وصلوا أيضًا
إلى بيانات معايير الأمان الخاصة بهم
، وبشكل أساسي ، فقد مضى
نصف المشاركين في التجربة على الأقل
منذ شهرين من
تلقي الطلقات
ولم يكن هناك العديد من
الآثار السلبية  ليس لدينا البيانات المحددة
التي نريد إلقاء نظرة عليها ،
لكن شركة Pfizer تعتقد بالتأكيد أن
ملف تعريف الأمان
جيد بما يكفي للمضي قدمًا والإرسال ، لذا
انظر
أننا نسمع أنه قد يكون هناك طلب
ترخيص استخدام طارئ
لهذا اللقاح  في غضون
الأسبوعين المقبلين
، وإذا كان هذا صحيحًا ، فسيتم الانتقال إلى
لجنة أخرى تحدد بعد ذلك
كيفية توزيع اللقاح
، وإذا حدث ذلك قبل عيد الميلاد ، فمن
المحتمل لأول مرة أن يتلقى الأشخاص خارج
التجارب السريرية
لقاح فيروس كورونا